los ingenieros que estudiaron ingeniería.
La verdad es que ellos ya no son la regla,
sino la excepción.
Un estudio del 2010 halló que solo un cuarto de los graduados
trabaja en un campo relacionado con su carrera.
Yo me gradué no con uno sino con dos títulos en biología.
Para desazón de mis padres, no soy doctor ni científico.
(Risas)
Años de estudiar la replicación del ADN y la fotosíntesis
poco me prepararon para una carrera en tecnología.
Tuve que aprender todo por mi cuenta: ventas, marketing, estrategia,
incluso un poco de programación, yo solo.
Nunca había tenido el título de Jefe de Producto
antes de enviar mi currículo a Etsy.
Ya me habían rechazado Google y varias otras compañías
y me estaba frustrando.
La compañía había entrado al mercado hacía poco,
por eso como parte de mi solicitud de trabajo
leí su oferta pública inicial de cabo a rabo
y diseñé un sitio web desde cero que incluía mi análisis del negocio
y cuatro ideas de nuevas funciones.
Resultó ser que el equipo estaba trabajando activamente en dos de esas
y estaba considerando seriamente otra.
Conseguí el empleo.
Todos conocemos casos de personas que fueron ignoradas al principio
pero terminaron derrotando a los críticos.
¿Mi historia favorita?
La de Brian Acton, un gerente de ingeniería
rechazado por Twitter y por Facebook
antes de cofundar WhatsApp,
la aplicación de mensajería móvil que luego se vendió por USD 19 000 millones.
La forma de contratar que construimos en el siglo XX nos falla
y produce que dejemos ir a personas con un potencial increíble.
Los avances en robótica y aprendizaje máquina
cambian la forma en que trabajamos,
automatizando las tareas rutinarias de muchos trabajos
a la vez que aumentan y amplifican la labor humana en otros.
A este ritmo, todos deberíamos contar con hacer trabajos que nunca hicimos
durante el resto de nuestra carrera.
Entonces ¿qué herramientas necesitamos
para identificar a los genios del mañana?
Buscando respuestas a esta pregunta me comuniqué con líderes de muchos sectores,
leí decenas de reseñas y trabajos de investigación
y realicé mis propios experimentos sobre el talento.
Mi búsqueda está muy lejos de terminar,
pero aquí hay tres ideas para tener en cuenta;
Uno: expande tu búsqueda.
Si solo buscamos talento en los mismos lugares de siempre:
escuelas para genios, universidades famosas,
organizaciones de prestigio,
vamos a obtener los resultados de siempre.
El béisbol cambió cuando los Atléticos de Oakland, cortos de dinero,
empezaron a reclutar jugadores
sin altos puntajes por ejemplo de carreras al bate
pero que tenían la capacidad de ayudar a su equipo
a anotar puntos y ganar.
Esta idea está asentándose fuera del deporte.
Un ejecutivo de Pinterest me dijo
que han construido uno de los equipos más diversos
y productivos de Silicon Valley
porque piensan que no solo un tipo de persona
tiene un monopolio sobre el talento.
Se fuerzan a ver más allá de los lugares tradicionales
y se enfocan en el portfolio del diseñador
no en su pedigrí.
Dos: contrata por desempeño.
Inspirado por mi propia experiencia laboral,
cofundé una plataforma de contratación llamada Headlight,
que les da a los candidatos una oportunidad de brillar.
Tal como las obras de teatro tienen ensayos,
a los candidatos se les pide que demuestren su talento
antes de ser contratados.
El cliente se beneficia de 85 años de investigación sobre contratación,
que señalan a las pruebas
como uno de los mejores predictores de éxito laboral.
¿Quieres a un analista de datos?
Dale una planilla con datos históricos y pregúntale qué puede determinar.
¿Buscas a un jefe de marketing?
Hazlo planear una campaña de lanzamiento.
Y si eres un candidato, no esperes que un empleador te lo pida.
Busca una forma de demostrar tus capacidades y talentos
más allá de tu currículo y carta de presentación.
Tres: ten una visión general.
He escuchado de reclutadores que califican a alguien de poco comprometido
por tan solo un trabajo donde estuvo poco tiempo;
he leído sobre profesores que ignoran aplicaciones idénticas de estudiantes
porque sus nombres son asiáticos o afroestadounidenses en vez de blancos.
Yo casi termino en un lugar para niños especiales.
A un mes de entrar a kindergarten,
mi maestra escribió una larga nota
que decía que era impulsivo,
tenía un período de atención corto,
y que a pesar de mi maravillosa curiosidad,
era cansador trabajar conmigo.
(Risas)
El director llamó a mis padres a una reunión,
le preguntó a mi madre si había sido un parto complicado
y sugirió que me viera con el psicólogo del kindergarten.
Mi padre vio lo que pasaba
y le explicó nuestra situación familiar.
Como inmigrantes recientes, vivíamos en el ático
de un asilo de ancianos con discapacidades mentales.
Mis padres trabajaban mucho para mantenernos,
y yo tenía pocas oportunidades de pasar tiempo con chicos de mi edad.
¿Era entonces una sorpresa que un chico de 5 años con pocos estímulos
se emocionara un poco en un salón lleno de niños
después de pasar todo un verano solo?
Hasta que no tengamos una visión global de alguien,
nuestros juicios sobre esa persona siempre van a estar errados.
Dejemos de igualar experiencia con capacidad,
credenciales con competencia.
Dejemos de conformarnos con la opción segura y familiar
y dejemos la puerta abierta para alguien que puede ser genial.
Necesitamos que los empleadores abandonen las prácticas anticuadas
y adopten nuevas formas de identificar y cultivar el talento,
y los candidatos pueden ayudar aprendiendo a contar su historia
de una forma fuerte y atractiva.
Podemos vivir en un mundo en el que veamos a las personas por lo que pueden hacer,
en el que tengan la oportunidad de lograr su máximo potencial.
Así que vayamos a construirlo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)